in ten nights I tape a Netflix 30
minutes it's called whatever the [ __ ]
it's called shenanigans who the [ __ ]
knows all he was done degenerates and I
started training a long [ __ ] time ago
for this but the last 14 days before the
shooters when I really condensed it I've
been going around town flappers - haha
[ __ ] like that and we go everywhere we
go to the fourth wall we want to show
you a lot of [ __ ] so stick around we'll
go for a ride
you ain't be ahead by over here now yeah
glass pants and a bunch of other movies
ladies and gent the world-famous Joey
time
someone knows everyone's in the holiday
the best option in that scenario is the
push
even though you get beat up becomes
active attack quality games I put myself
in positions as well 55 at our old high
school sling and dictators
right now I'm headed to the comedy store
I'm gonna open up Joe's show and get the
[ __ ] back over there that New York trip
[ __ ] me up last week staying up one
night the homeland is not healthy flee
without drugs especially you know hey
stay up all the [ __ ] time now I can't
do it no more
Billy we were headed down to the Comedy
Store Walt Canyon it's just about sex
right now and riding in the daytime and
putting it all together I got to come up
with 28 minutes I got about 20 but every
day you had a minute some [ __ ] line
some stupid thing enjoy watching we go
to this is the real [ __ ] deal here
I'm going on to akame stole the [ __ ]
murderers row
one of these [ __ ] enemies look at
these of them people it's packed this is
the real deal Holyfield tonight from
why'd you cut me off [ __ ]
like an alter ego seven things I take
off my [ __ ] brain I'll give myself a
reason when I thought it was funny
get my college to reach out that's what
you do right at home but it's a finger
on stage think about reasons why you
know [ __ ] miserable [ __ ] Savage
I never stopped at the bank
that's one night's work we got 10 more
[ __ ] nights and who gives a [ __ ] you
bomb tonight you come back tomorrow you
have a roast beef sandwich you keep
writing I guess is it I shut the camera
off where has it all
you guys Joey Diaz Sami the monkey was
smelling that gyro sauce
you